après 15 ans montréal kent nagano entame
sa dernière année à la tête de l'om
une période qui lui aura permis de
laisser sa marque sur la métropole mais
l'inversé est aussi vrai le maestro son
épouse la pianiste mari kodama pour
accepter de partager leurs coups de
coeur dans la métropole
ils ont profité des nombreuses bonnes
tables de la ville et pas seulement des
restaurants étoilés
une autre est ce que ma femme et moi on
a trouvé c'est pratiquement petit
restaurant japonais qui ce pas là pour
la sarthe au tour ongles tout petit mais
avec un cuisine qui fait la compétition
avec les meilleurs restos c'est la
cuisine simple mais extrêmement raffiné
sa médias c'est honnête c'est la qualité
et on se sent à la maison durant son
passage dans la métropole
le couple et nagano a aussi appris à
profiter des joies de l'hiver sont
rebelles
naturellement je suis devenu un absolu
fou qu'elle était en fait un homme c'est
un adresse pour tout le monde qui a
apprécié le plan et sans qui il faut
connaître une passion qu'il partage avec
son épouse
je n'ai pas grandi dans la culture de
suivre une groupe de sport c'était
vraiment une découverte pour moi
et je suis complètement addict est ok
maintenant et évidemment pour les
canadiens
le couple de mélomanes se passionne
également pour l'art visuel bien sûr le
musée des beaux-arts
je vais là-bas régulièrement c'est pour
moi pour une ville de taille de montréal
je connais très très chanceux d'avoir
le musée de ces qualités là
mais le maestro là sur sa meilleure
adresse de mort la maison symphonique
inauguré sous son règne et pour laquelle
il s'est beaucoup dévoué
maestro nagano son épouse et les
musiciens le sm animaux cette fin de
semaine le quartier des spectacles avec
la virée classique
au programme une trentaine de concerts
une quarantaine d'activités gratuites
l'occasion de venir saluer le co une
avant dernière fois ici nabi alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]